the music business is only designed to
get as many people to go away from God
as possible so what happens is the devil
needs workers and by workers he needs
people who have influence who can
mislead or misguide people away from
their life into the darkness so this is
why the artist is powerful so the artist
is the mouthpiece okay that artist is
the mouthpiece between the devil and the
fan and the artist's job is to get you
to throw up these weird signs what are
you doing this for this is the bot for
me I don't so don't think I'm
throwing this up cause I I don't this
I'm just showing you when you see these
signs when you see the checkerboards
when you hear them talking about demon
time and drill and kill and all this
even the actual beat in the BPM it's all
808 drums or low vibrational
so what happens is the artist is only
the tool used to push the message of the
devil
brothers and sisters as you can see
we've acquired the property and we're
getting right to work and with your duas
and support we can go ahead and get the
Masjid and megadawa Center up open and
running in sha Allah imagine every
person that prays here gets educated and
guided to Islam here you'll get a part
of all those blessings and rewards insha
Allah what are you waiting for brothers
and sisters you're going to leave it all
behind anyway so go ahead and invest in
your Hereafter that's Everlasting click
the link below donate right now may God
Almighty Allah reward all of you
[Music]
subscribe if you haven't already hit
that notification Bell I'm asking you a
question are you someone who listens to
musicians such as let's say Drake Lady
Gaga
Chris Brown Kate Perry Jay-Z and the
like
I could go on and on but you get the
point people who are basically
controlled by the satanic forces or as
some might call it the Matrix well let's
explore their lives and find out what
they're really about and what they
represent I saw my soul for you
now figure that out let's take a look at
Beyonce for example or the Gin called
Sasha that she describes possessing her
they're expecting
sure
she can
do things that I cannot do when I'm in
rehearsal I mean I can try but then it
just doesn't happen I can sing notes and
sing Strong and do all these things that
when I'm just by myself I can't do and I
remember right before I performed
I raised my hands up
and it was kind of the first time I I
felt something else
come into me and I knew
that was going to be my coming out night
we'll look at together these symbols
that they keep using and the meanings
behind them how black magic Satanism and
Kabbalah is all part of the industry
let's learn about the term called
channeling and how famous celebrities
such as Jack Nicholson even Warren Keith
Ledger about channeling in a certain
role right before he died also what's
this term rain man that we hear Eminem
talking about
boring me
and Jay-Z where is this going what is
this track say yeah
and I go through my rain man we'll also
learn about one of the most famous
musicians Bob Dylan making a bargain a
bargain with who should I ask who you
made the bargain with
with you know with the chief we'll also
learn about what people do to get famous
and at what cost people like forsake
their their moral code
finally at the end you'll learn about
Drew happiness and then I'll let you
make a decision at the end after you
watch this which of the two ways do you
want to be upon that I don't even want
to look like Katy Perry anymore so now
what I'm going to need you to do is sit
with me as we watch this together and at
the end you're going to be much more
informed about what goes on behind the
scenes and then you're going to have to
ask yourself a question at the end do I
still want to continue listening to
people like this have you ever wondered
why music artists use strange symbols
and gestures in their music videos and
concerts if if you have not then you're
not alone most of the people fail to see
a deeper connection between these
artists and the satanical cult groups
one cannot but ask himself these
questions what are these symbols that
reoccur everywhere in the entertainment
business why are these symbols used by
artists over and over again where do
these symbols come from what is the
meaning behind these symbols if you
don't have an answer to these questions
then you have no right to dismiss this
case
you analyze Satanism you will come to
the conclusion that it's very prevalent
in the music industry Satanism or black
magic is based on the worship of Satan
and neglecting the worship of God
Satanism reached its peak in Egypt at
the time of the Pharaohs this is why a
lot of the symbolism can be traced back
to this civilization you will see a lot
of Egyptian symbolism in the music
industry
here's an example of the owl that the
Egyptians used
does it look familiar to you
yes this same owl is used by the rap
artist Drake
Drake can also be seen doing the 666
hand gesture
each finger represents the number six
making it the sign of the devil with one
eye
here's the same owl on a satanic
ceremony called The Bohemian Grove
and here you see rap artist azithia
banks with the one eye and owls
this is an ancient 30th Danish tea
Egyptian falcon
see the same bird toot on the singer
Rihanna
this is a Lester Crowley dressed as an
Egyptian pharaoh he is considered as the
most notorious satanic Magician of the
20th century
he identifies himself as the prophet
entrusted with guiding Humanity into the
age of Horus in the early 20th century
Horus is yet again an Egyptian god here
you see rap artist Jay-Z wearing a quote
to what thou Wilt which comes from the
philosophy of dilemma which was
developed by Alessa Crowley this
religion includes a number of deities
primarily adapted from ancient Egypt
foreign
yet again you can clearly see the links
between these artists and Satanism but
still the people pay no heed and
continue as if they saw not
also notice the same triangle and I the
Satan Institute can also be found on the
American one dollar bill why is the
government using satanic symbols
Assassin's Creed is a video game series
which primarily revolves around the
Rivalry between two ancient secret
societies the assassins and the Knights
Templar and their indirect relation to
an ancient species predating Humanity
referred to within the games as those
who came before
we know before God created humans he
created the Jinn including Satan the
latest release of this video game is
called Assassin's Creed Origins which is
about how these secret societies started
and you can guess it it is in ancient
Egypt
the secret societies want to control
Humanity
although this is just a video game it
has a lot of Truth in it
I want to represent the idea that you
really can make what you want one of my
favorite books is the The Alchemist uh
Paulo Coelho and
that's just I just believe that I
believe that
I can create whatever I want to create
if I can put my head on it right study
it learn the patterns and you know I
just I it's hard to put into words real
in this clip we hear the actor Will
Smith talk about the book The Alchemist
by Paolo kooho
when we look at the cover of this book
we can see it again the link to the
Egyptian civilization
will also talks about that he can create
everything he wants
this is a satanic philosophy because
only Allah has the authority to create
whatever he wants
Satan tells his worshipers to do
whatever thou Wilt and neglect whatever
Allah wants the philosophy behind do
what thou Wilt is that Satan wants you
to do whatever your desires tell you and
neglect the worship of Allah
[Music]
Alchemy is a seemingly magical process
of transformation creation or
combination yes a magical process black
magic to be more precise
if we look up the symbols used in
alchemy we can see some familiar symbols
am I right
here we see another symbol used in
Alchemy
now look at the album cover of the
rapper Lupe Fiasco are these people
artists or are these people magicians
that is up to you to decide
Anton LaVey was an American occultist
and was labeled by many as the father of
Satanism he was the founder of the
Church of Satan and the religion of Levy
and Satanism he authored several books
including the Satanic Bible the Satanic
rituals and the satanic witch
here you can see him do a Satanic hand
sign
does it look familiar to you this hand
sign is very prevalent in the music
industry this is not just a mere
coincidence the devil is hiding in plain
sight
here you can see rap artist ASAP Rocky
on a satanic pentagram why do we keep on
seeing links to satanism this is not in
one time occurrence it keeps on
happening over and over again it is now
up to us to draw conclusions
[Music]
here is singer Beyonce with a demonic
performant ring this performance symbol
is widely used in Satanism if these
artists have nothing to do with Satanism
then why do they keep on associating
themselves with satanic symbolism
but there Still Remains one question
unanswered why do all these artists
worship the devil what do they get in
return
these artists perform Satanic rituals to
please the Jinn or demons the Jinn are
another creation of God they are made
out of fire and Satan is one of the Jinn
these Jinn will help these artists if
they worship them the devil worshipers
hope to humiliate themselves in order
for these demonic entities to help them
they sacrifice animals and even engage
in pedophilia and homosexuality in order
to get demonic powers
here's an example of the singer Lady
Gaga who talks about demons possessing
her
and your favorite scary story
my favorite scary story the one that I'm
going to dream about tomorrow night
have incessant nightmares but I've
learned to
love them
because they somehow end up on stage
during my work
what's that say
I'm also terrified of the devil
well that the next question I'm going to
ask you is from Tatton in Hong Kong
which is do you believe in God yes and
the devil and the devil I believe in
both
I had this dream quite recently that was
so terrifying so morbid and terrifying
and I called
um
I called Deepak Chopra who I work with
and I was
telling him my dream terrified that the
devil and I the dream was so terrifying
I thought somehow a a devil force was
trying to
take hold of me a Darkness I I guess I
see devil in darkness is the same thing
and he left and told me that I was very
creative Beyonce talks about another
entity taking over her when she performs
calling her Sasha Fierce they're
expecting Sasha
and
um
I'm really kind of shy and not really
shy but more reserved and
um nothing like Sasha no she can she can
do things that I cannot do when I'm in
rehearsal I mean I can try but then it
just doesn't happen I can sing notes and
sing Strong and do all these things that
when I'm just by myself I can't do and I
remember right before I performed
I raised my hands up and it was kind of
the first time I I felt something else
come into me and I knew
that was going to be my coming out night
for the BET Awards
is not uncommon for satanists to develop
multiple personalities
because their bodies get possessed by
these demons and help them perform
channeling the act or practice of
serving as a medium through which a
spirit purportedly communicates with
living persons that's the definition of
channeling a lot of these actors believe
in channeling
so they actually invoke Spirits I think
why you're my role model has to do with
the way you relate
to vanity
we're lying in bed and we're rehearsing
the astronaut Garrett Reed love seat and
then we launched into the First Take
and two voices came out of you do you
remember this two voices and they were
they were simultaneous words but they
were two levels of sound
and I looked over at you you were amazed
I was amazing you said well sure sure
I'm I'm many different people
said no Jack you're channeling
Too Tall coming out two voices at the
same time
clear they go they do what's called
method acting where they invoke Crowley
said the quickest way to invoke a spirit
is through acting
so they do a method technique and they
stay in character for the entire film
Jack Nicholson in some films scared
people because he would play Psychopaths
and he would stay in character even when
the filming wasn't being filmed and it
was like he was possessed because that's
what they do Heath Ledger who played The
Joker and and and and that had
previously been played by Jack Nicholson
when he was killed they asked they told
Jack Nicholson and asked him what he
thought he said I warned him about that
role
that's what he had to say
here's Jay-Z in the studio recording a
song
look close at the book that is present
in the studio
a book named white and black magic
[Music]
is this where they get their lyrics from
Jay-Z also talks about something called
rain man taking over him when he raps
this right here we call a Magic Moment
right now I'm thinking like
you know we're just going what does this
track say
when I go through my Rain Man it's funny
like uh how it came about being nurses
is weird because I started out
technically like I used to write all the
time you know before I started uh going
into the rain man thing you know
so what do who is this rain man that he
keeps on talking about let's listen to
another satanic artist Eminem yeah proof
my name ain't gonna be Slim Shady no
more so no more Swift shake no more
Eminem No More Eminem
[Music]
[Applause]
Rain Man listen close to the lyrics of
this song
[Music]
rapper Lil Uzi vert is a new age artist
who blew up recently selling millions of
Records
his name Lil Uzi vert sounds like
Lucifer which is her name also given to
Satan
you can see satanic symbols everywhere
[Music]
he even admitted selling his soul to the
devil in a live stream
I saw my soul for you now figure that
out
myself I saw my soul for you
but are you on here that's asking me
that I sell my soul how the is
y'all on here if y'all think I saw my
soul
you know coming right with me you
dummies get dummies get dummies
for as long as I've been here in 60
minutes I've wanted to interview Bob
Dylan over his 43-year career there is
no musician alive who has been more
influential his distinctive Twang and
poetic lyrics have produced some of the
most memorable songs ever written you
ever look at music that you've written
and look back at it and say whoa that
surprised me
I don't know how
I got to write those songs or those
early songs were like almost magically
written
um uh that there's a magic to that and
it's not uh Siegfried and Roy kind of
magic you know it's a it's a different
kind of a penetrating magic why do you
still do it why are you still out here
well it goes back to the destiny thing
bargain with it
a long time ago and
holding up my hand what was your bargain
to get where
I am now should I ask who you make the
bargain with
with you know with the chief uh chief
commander on this Earth and this Earth
and then in the world we can't see world
we can't see
this is a performance by the singer
Chris Brown and rap a tiger at the BET
Awards
why do these artists love Egypt so much
[Music]
these are some tattoos that Chris Brown
has
this is Kenny West with the same
Egyptian Eagle as a necklace
[Music]
[Applause]
like a Happy Meal
Cabana is the original form of black
magic which was first practiced by the
Jews
all these artists practice Kabbalah in
different forms by worshiping Satan
[Music]
this is a cabala red string or Crimson
string which the practitioner wears when
he interacts with demons
we can see numerous celebrities wearing
this red string
[Music]
the most often used symbol in Satanism
is the one eye
but what is the meaning behind the one
eye
we can find the answer in the Holy Quran
in this verse Allah talks about all two
eyes and about the two ways one way is
the way of righteousness and the other
way of evil
two eyes symbolize that we can
distinguish between the two ways truth
and falsehood they symbolize the
knowledge of this world and the
knowledge of the Hereafter both
unnecessary to be a good Muslim
this is why Satan uses the one eye to
symbolize the evil way
it closes the other eye the Eye of Truth
the eye from which we acquire Divine
knowledge of Allah Satan wants you to
neglect the next life and get everything
you want in this life
he wants you to do whatever thou Wilt
except the one thing you are made to do
worship God
do not think that these artists are
happy most of them end up doing drugs
and committing suicide
remember the only way to happiness is
the way of Allah
you feel like an imposter
when someone thinks you're something in
there and you're not yeah I feel sad
when uh I'm overworked and that I just
become a money-making machine and that
my passion and my creativity take a back
seat that makes men happy I so badly
want to be Catherine Hudson that I don't
even want to look like Katy Perry
anymore sometimes okay
and like that is a little bit of why
I cut my hair is because I really want
to be my authentic self like a hundred
percent
sure if your ultimate goal is to be
famous then you're gonna do a lot to do
to get there like sign your name in
blood in a contract with the devil like
you're gonna end up in on a one-way
Street and it's going nowhere like
that's just the truth I've been I've
seen so many people like forsake their
their their moral code and their value
systems just for a little bit of Fame
and it's it's not worth it at the end of
the day it's really not really not worth
it not worth it not
[Music]
foreign foreign
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go and visit thedenshow.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you our brother
in Islam Eddie from the dean show is
creating the dean Dean Center which is a
Masjid and a dawa Center which is going
to help non-muslims learn about Islam
insha Allah and the most beautiful thing
about this is that we can all be a part
of this we can all take part in earning
rewards from this simply by donating
whatever we can to make this a reality
which is beautiful let's do that all
right let's click this link let's donate
what we can and let's make this a
reality insha Allah
[Music]
foreign